Squeezie - Freestyle de l'autodérison
Bon, aujourd'hui j'voulais faire une chanson, mais j'savais pas trop de quoi parler.
Puis je me suis rappelé qu'j'était qu'une p'tite merde qui as trop pris la confiance
Du coup, je vais me faire redescendre un peu.
Mais pour une fois on va arrêter de se cacher derrière une voix grave, et on va assumer notre voix peu virile d'adolescent de 15 ans.
On y va.
Fais pas genre t'es déjà tombé sur mes vidéos
Un mec pas très drôle, comme ils disent "une star des ados"
J'arrête pas de dire que j'ai grandi car j'ai attendu ça longtemps
J'ai kiffé quand j'ai eu ma barbe, plus que le jour de mes 18 ans
J'suis plus les modes sur YouTube, que tu suis les gens sur Twitter
Depuis l'enfance on m'le répète "Quand est-ce que tu va chez le coiffeur" ?"
J'me suis fait tout seul, si tout seul c'est Cyprien, mon corps on dirait une feuille, la muscu j'connais pas bien
9 millions d'abonnés, seulement 12 amis sur Facebook, dans la vie j'suis plus nul qu'un mec de l'émission "Change de look"
Ma première musique a marché
Mais j'ai rien inventé, j'suis la parfaite fusion nulle
De Nekfeu et Keen V
J'dis toujours que j'ai un corps de lâche pour faire genre que je l'assume
Mais j'vais tout m'faire refaire, maintenant qu'j'ai des thunes
Tu cliques fais gaffe, mes cris t'agacent, c'est loin d'être satisfaisant
J'suis méprisant, j'suis médisant, j'fait kiffer qu'ton fils de 10 ans
🔥 Freestyle, Freestyle de l'autodérision, Freestyle, Freestyle de l'autodérision, Freestyle, Freestyle de l'autodérision 🔥
🔥 Et si tu sais pas rire de toi même, t'es juste con ! 🔥
[Musique]
"Tu feras quoi après YouTube ?"
T'inquiètes faut pas être peureux. J'pointerai au Pôle emploi quand tous mes potes seront plus vieux.
J'passerais d'un enfant gâté
qu'a toujours eu ce qu'il voulait
à un vieux con raté, qui regrette ses jours passés
Prêt à tout pour faire des vues :
Animaux et famille
Loin des sujets importants :
réchauffement et famine
J'envoie plus d'amour à des gens
que j'connais pas qu'à mes proches
Trop d'égo pour me remettre en question
J'accepte pas les reproches
Accro aux stats
tous les jours j'tâte
Les plus grand talents d'YouTube
Je copie les autres
c'est pas ma faute
faire le buzz toutes les semaines c'est rude
J'fais la morale à d'autres
comme si j'étais au dessus
Mais comme beaucoup d'potes j'ai changé
c'est sûr j'les ai déçus
Dans l'écran
on m'aime
J'suis un mec cool, heureux et bienveillant.
Dans la vie
Je m'aime
j'suis juste un mégalo pas marrant.
Je digère mal les réaction des gens
j'ai que la vingtaine.
Pourtant mes vidéos qui marchent le mieux
sont celles où j'filme les miennes
🔥 Freestyle, Freestyle de l'autodérision, Freestyle, Freestyle de l'autodérision, Freestyle, Freestyle de l'autodérision 🔥
🔥 Et si tu sais pas rire de toi même, t'es juste con ! 🔥
[Musique]
-FIN-
CLIQUEZ SUR LE LOGO POUR VOUS ABONNER SI VOUS LE SOUHAITEZ !
ET CLIQUEZ SUR LA VIDÉO POUR LA REGARDER ! MERCI. AU REVOIR !